This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Hey Roman. Hey Deline Hall, you're the executive producer of this here show. Yes, I am, and I'm going to be telling our story this week. I want to start back in November 2016. Was election night. Who could forget? And somewhere in New York City, there was a group of friends watching the results come in.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。嘿，罗曼。嘿，德琳·霍尔，你是这个节目的执行制片人。是的，我是，本周将由我来讲述我们的故事。我想从2016年11月说起。那是选举之夜。谁能忘记呢？在纽约市的某个地方，有一群朋友正在观看计票结果。
A few of them had been low-level volunteers for the Hillary Clinton campaign. Donald Trump has won the state of Florida. One of his Trump will win Ohio. Trump will carry the state of Wisconsin. He will win Wisconsin. And the results were not what they were expecting. And the wall comes to him down. This is the blue wall that Hillary Clinton had talked about. This is a state of Hillary Clinton. As they watched, they were getting more and more upset. The middle is very bad at that point.
他们中有几个人曾是希拉里·克林顿竞选团队的基层志愿者。唐纳德·特朗普赢得了佛罗里达州。特朗普将赢得俄亥俄州。特朗普将拿下威斯康星州。他将赢得威斯康星州。结果并非他们所预料的那样。那堵墙倒塌了。这就是希拉里·克林顿所说的“蓝墙”。这是希拉里·克林顿的州。当他们看着这一切时，他们变得越来越沮丧。那一刻，心情糟透了。
It's still we still in blame, it was real. We wondered if there was a counting error or there's all big cosmic joke. So yeah, shocked bordering on depression basically. Okay, so who's that and what's up with his voice? So that is a member of the group that was there that night and we have agreed to keep him anonymous, which is why his voice sounds like that. I'll explain more later.
我们仍然处于指责之中，这太真实了。我们怀疑是不是计票出了错，或者这只是一个巨大的宇宙玩笑。所以，是的，震惊到近乎抑郁。好吧，那个人是谁？他的声音怎么了？那是那天晚上在场的一位成员，我们已经同意让他保持匿名，这就是为什么他的声音听起来是那样的。我稍后会解释更多。
Okay, it's very mysterious. Thank you, Cohen. So this group is freaking out. Everybody's spiraling. There's a lot of existential dread going on. Like, what is this going to mean? One of my first thoughts, oddly enough, I don't even know why I thought this is this guy's gonna get a library.
好吧，这太神秘了。谢谢，科恩。所以这群人吓坏了。每个人都在崩溃。有一种强烈的存在主义恐惧感。就像，这意味着什么？奇怪的是，我最初的想法之一是——我甚至不知道为什么会这么想——这家伙会拥有一座图书馆。
Like how do you get Donald Trump a presidential library? In this moment, he's thinking about Donald Trump's future presidential library. I have to say that that was not where my head was. And the election night. Nor mine, nor mine. But this guy is actually an architect. Oh, okay.
就像你怎么给唐纳德·特朗普建一座总统图书馆？在这一刻，他竟然在想唐纳德·特朗普未来的总统图书馆。我不得不说，那不是我当时想到的。选举之夜也不是我想的。我也没想过。但这家伙其实是一位建筑师。哦，好吧。
And I won't say much more than that, but he does live in New York where Trump made his career as a developer. And so that's where this guy's head went. Yeah, I mean, bookish isn't the first adjective when I think about Donald Trump. When he talks about his favorite book, he usually mentions his own, uh, goes written autobiography. Yeah, he is by many accounts, not a big reader. So it seems a little contradictory at first, the idea of a Trump library, but I will admit that like this architect, I've become a little bit fascinated by the question of this hypothetical library. Where will it be? You know, what will it look like?
我不会多说别的，但他确实住在纽约，特朗普在那里以开发商的身份开启了他的职业生涯。所以这就是这家伙的思路。是的，我的意思是，当想到唐纳德·特朗普时，“书卷气”并不是第一个浮现在脑海里的形容词。当他谈到自己最喜欢的书时，他通常会提到他自己的代笔自传。是的，据许多人说，他不是一个爱读书的人。所以，特朗普图书馆的想法起初看起来有点矛盾，但我承认，像这位建筑师一样，我也对这个假设的图书馆产生了点兴趣。它会在哪里？你知道，它会是什么样子？
Will it be gold? Will there be a gold plated roller coaster? That's what I want to know. But as I started learning about the history of presidential libraries more generally, I've kind of think there's actually something quite Trumpian about them, like all of them, regardless of the president involved. Oh, interesting. Yeah, I can kind of see that. They've always felt more like a museum to one person's greatness than anything else. That seems quite Trumpian in some ways.
会是金色的吗？会有镀金的过山车吗？这就是我想知道的。但当我开始更广泛地了解总统图书馆的历史时，我发现它们实际上有一种非常“特朗普式”的特质，就像所有的图书馆一样，无论涉及哪位总统。哦，有意思。是的，我能理解。它们一直以来给人的感觉更像是某个人伟大的博物馆，而不是其他什么。这在某些方面看起来确实很“特朗普”。
Yeah, exactly. There's weird mix of historical repository of records and things that have one meaning, and there also then this edifice, this self-congratuary, almost fictional account of someone's achievements where the blotishes are hidden. So we'll get back to this architect in a little bit, but first I want to tell you about how presidential libraries came to be because they have always been a weird contradiction. Oh, I'm excited. Let's do it. So before the invention of presidential libraries, there was just chaos when it came to presidential records.
是的，没错。这里有一种奇怪的混合体，既是历史记录的存储库，又是一种自我吹捧、几乎是虚构的个人成就记录，掩盖了所有的污点。所以我们稍后再回到这位建筑师身上，但首先我想告诉你总统图书馆是如何产生的，因为它们一直是一个奇怪的矛盾体。哦，我很兴奋。我们开始吧。在总统图书馆发明之前，总统记录的处理简直是一团糟。
A lot of George Washington's papers were eaten by rats. A lot of other people's papers burned in fires. This is Jollipore. She's a historian at Harvard and a writer at the New Yorker and she's the host of a great podcast called The Last Archive. And she says that in the early years of the country, people were just burning presidential papers in trash cans or pulling out all the unflattering documents and destroying them. The papers that remain give you a very distorted portrait of the person, right? So any evidence of
乔治·华盛顿的许多文件被老鼠吃了。其他许多人的文件在火灾中烧毁了。这是吉尔·莱波雷。她是哈佛大学的历史学家，《纽约客》的撰稿人，也是一个很棒的播客《最后的档案》的主持人。她说，在这个国家的早期，人们只是把总统文件扔进垃圾桶烧掉，或者挑出所有不光彩的文件并销毁它们。剩下的文件会给你一个非常扭曲的人物画像，对吧？所以任何证据
scandal or corruption will have been very carefully ex-sized by your children or your grandchildren or your wife or your widow. And for a long time, that was the state of things. Presidential papers were considered the private property of the president. And what happened to them was very haphazard. It sounds like what God saved was shaped by a mix of chaos and self-interest. So on the one hand, what's left behind is kind of accidental.
丑闻或腐败都会被你的孩子、孙子、妻子或遗孀非常小心地剔除。在很长一段时间里，情况就是这样。总统文件被认为是总统的私有财产。它们的遭遇非常随意。听起来上帝保存下来的东西是由混乱和私利混合而成的。所以一方面，留下的东西是偶然的。
And on the other hand, what's left behind is the stuff that makes the person look good. And it really wasn't until the progressive era, like the late 1800s, early 1900s, that that started to change in any kind of systematic way. And that was the era when people were starting to talk about good governments and the ideas of openness and transparency. And increasingly by the 1930s, that's understood in opposition to the secrecy of authoritarian regimes that are toppling democracies the world over, right? Especially thinking of, you know, Mussolini and Hitler.
另一方面，留下的东西是那些让人看起来不错的东西。直到进步时代，也就是19世纪末20世纪初，这种情况才开始以某种系统性的方式改变。那是人们开始谈论良好政府、开放和透明理念的时代。到了20世纪30年代，这种理念日益被理解为与世界各地推翻民主制度的威权政权的秘密相对立，对吧？特别是想到墨索里尼和希特勒。
So this is the era when the national archives were established, you know, to care and preserve for the records of the US government. And those documents, like presidential papers, had just been kept in basements and addicts and various abandoned buildings scattered across Washington, DC. And again, the disarray is just shocking to me. Like, this is what I would do with my import documents, but like the documents of the nation, anyway. Then Franklin Delano Roosevelt came along, and by the end of his second term, he'd come up with a plan for his own papers.
所以这是国家档案馆成立的时代，旨在照管和保存美国政府的记录。而那些文件，比如总统文件，之前只是被存放在华盛顿特区各处的地下室、阁楼和各种废弃建筑中。再说一次，这种混乱让我感到震惊。就像，这就是我会处理我重要文件的方式，但这是国家的文件，总之。后来富兰克林·德拉诺·罗斯福出现了，到他第二个任期结束时，他已经为自己的文件想出了一个计划。
He decided that he was going to put all his papers in one place and that it would be open to the public. Roosevelt was the one that came up with this idea that I could have a museum that would celebrate my life. This is Benjamin Huffbauer. He's an art historian and an expert on presidential libraries. And I'd have this archive, and it would be a building, and he was an amateur architect, so he designed his own... his own little building for that. It was designed in the Dutch colonial style style and it wasn't actually that little. It was about 40,000 square feet.
他决定把所有的文件放在一个地方，并向公众开放。罗斯福是第一个提出“我可以建一个博物馆来庆祝我的一生”这个想法的人。这是本杰明·霍夫鲍尔。他是一位艺术史学家，也是总统图书馆方面的专家。我会拥有这个档案馆，它会是一座建筑，他本人是一位业余建筑师，所以他为那个……为那个小建筑做了设计。它采用荷兰殖民风格设计，其实并不算小。它大约有4万平方英尺。
And Roosevelt decided that it would be built in Hyde Park, New York, the place where he was born. And to raise the funds for it, he turned to his supporters. So supporters of President Roosevelt could mail in a check for $10, $20, $50, $100, and that went into the funding of the library. Then once the building was completed, then it was handed over to the federal government to the National Archives to be run forever, basically, by the U.S. government. And this latest addition to the archives of America is dedicated at a moment when government of the people by themselves is being attacked everywhere.
罗斯福决定把它建在纽约的海德公园，他出生的地方。为了筹集资金，他求助于他的支持者。所以罗斯福总统的支持者可以寄来10美元、20美元、50美元、100美元的支票，这些钱就进入了图书馆的资金池。建筑完工后，它被移交给联邦政府，由国家档案馆永久管理，基本上是由美国政府运营。而这个美国档案馆的最新成员，是在人民自己治理的政府在各地受到攻击的时刻落成的。
And so that was it, the first presidential library. It opened in 1941. Wow, that seems so recent in American history. So when this thing opened in 41, how did people react to it? Like how was it received? Oh, a lot of people thought it was ridiculous. People thought he was a megalomaniac. Someone said he wanted to build a Yankee pyramid. There was a comic that portrayed FDR as Santa Claus presenting a giant president
这就是第一个总统图书馆。它于1941年开放。哇，这在美洲历史上似乎太近了。所以当这个东西在41年开放时，人们有什么反应？它是如何被接受的？哦，很多人认为这很荒谬。人们认为他是个自大狂。有人说他想建一座“扬基金字塔”。有一幅漫画把富兰克林·罗斯福描绘成圣诞老人，把一个巨大的总统
in his own stocking and saying of the presidential librarians, oh, won't you be surprised? Bless his heart. Oh, oh. Well, it seems like the public had a pretty good take on what the library actually was. It got kind of like a monument that FDR built to himself. Yeah, and while he was alive, no less.
放进他自己的长袜里，并对总统图书馆员说，哦，你不感到惊讶吗？真是好心肠。哦，哦。好吧，看来公众对这个图书馆到底是什么有相当准确的看法。它有点像富兰克林·罗斯福为自己建造的纪念碑。是的，而且是在他活着的时候。
Like, that was really not done at the time. The tradition was that monuments to presidents were built long after they had died. The Washington Monument, for example, was finished in the mid-1880s, about 85 years after George Washington died. And the Lincoln Memorial was dedicated in 1922, nearly 60 years after Abraham Lincoln's death. Yeah, normally there's this big gap and only the most exceptional presidents get a monument. And here we've got monuments right away to each president as they're still living, sometimes
这在当时确实是不被允许的。传统上，总统的纪念碑是在他们去世很久之后才建造的。例如，华盛顿纪念碑是在19世纪80年代中期完成的，大约在乔治·华盛顿去世85年后。林肯纪念堂于1922年落成，距离亚伯拉罕·林肯去世近60年。是的，通常会有很大的间隔，只有最杰出的总统才能获得纪念碑。而在这里，我们为每一位总统在他们还活着的时候就立即建造了纪念碑，有时
as they're still in office. But the FDR library ended up setting the template for presidential libraries going forward. In 1955, Congress passed the Presidential Libraries Act, which formalized this idea of privately built and publicly administered institutions. The next one that went up was the Truman Library in Independence, Missouri, and it was structured like FDRs. So it was a branch of the National Archives. It was full of, you know, actual important documents.
在他们还在任时。但富兰克林·罗斯福图书馆最终为未来的总统图书馆设定了模板。1955年，国会通过了《总统图书馆法》，将这种私人建造、公共管理的机构理念正式化。下一个建成的是密苏里州独立城的杜鲁门图书馆，它的结构和富兰克林·罗斯福的一样。所以它是国家档案馆的一个分支。它里面装满了，你知道，真正重要的文件。
It really did improve access for researchers. But its museum was also basically a shrine to Truman. And it raised for me the question of, you know, how do we as Americans tell our stories? This is Bruce Schulman. He's a historian at Boston University. He has visited most of the existing presidential libraries. How do we teach history? How do we speak about it? So I think I just accidentally became interested in those questions.
它确实改善了研究人员的获取途径。但它的博物馆基本上也是杜鲁门的圣殿。这对我提出了一个问题，你知道，我们作为美国人如何讲述我们的故事？这是布鲁斯·舒尔曼。他是波士顿大学的历史学家。他参观过现存的大多数总统图书馆。我们如何教授历史？我们如何谈论它？所以我认为我只是偶然对这些问题产生了兴趣。
And you know, you can probably guess the way the presidential story gets told in the Truman Library, but also others. It's fundamentally this heroic story about how an extraordinary person comes along at a pivotal moment in American history, changing the country's destiny. And that kind of gets at the essential tension between the work that's being done in the archive and what it is those shrines are trying to do, which is to create a largely feel good celebration of the American past and this particular president's role in it. the American past and this particular president's role in it. I think there are monuments to the vanity of ex-presidents, which is immeasurable.
你知道，你可能猜得到总统的故事在杜鲁门图书馆以及其他图书馆中是如何讲述的。这本质上是一个英雄故事，讲述了一个非凡的人如何在美洲历史的关键时刻出现，改变了国家的命运。这触及了档案馆所做的工作与这些圣殿试图做的事情之间的本质张力，即创造一种对美国过去和这位特定总统角色的、很大程度上让人感觉良好的庆祝。我认为这些是前总统虚荣心的纪念碑，这种虚荣心是不可估量的。
No, Jill the poor always calls it like she sees it. You know, and she is not wrong. There are so many interesting examples of how these huge presidential egos end up manifesting in their buildings. But I think my favorite is the Lyndon Baines Johnson Library in Austin, Texas. It is a stunning building. It's just massive. Beautiful, Travertine marble, imported from Italy covers the entire thing
不，吉尔·莱波雷总是直言不讳。你知道，她没有错。有太多有趣的例子说明这些巨大的总统自我意识最终是如何在他们的建筑中体现出来的。但我最喜欢的是德克萨斯州奥斯汀的林登·贝恩斯·约翰逊图书馆。这是一座令人惊叹的建筑。它非常宏伟。从意大利进口的漂亮洞石覆盖了整个建筑。
Which has almost no windows except right before the top floor which is can't delivered out and has glass beneath it So it looks almost like it's kind of floating it looks kind of like a cross between a Space age bureaucracy and an Egyptian pylon temple We really have to see pictures of it to kind of believe it. And this building was starting to go up in 1967, 1968, towards the end of LBJ's time in office. And you know, that was a very consequential time. There was a lot going on.
除了顶层正下方几乎没有窗户，顶层是悬挑出来的，下面有玻璃，所以它看起来几乎像是漂浮着。它看起来有点像太空时代官僚机构和埃及塔门神庙的结合体。我们真的必须看到它的照片才能相信。这座建筑在1967年、1968年开始动工，也就是林登·约翰逊任期快结束的时候。你知道，那是一个非常重要的时期。发生了很多事情。
You've got, of course, more than 500,000 American troops in Vietnam. Martin Luther King Jr. of course is tragically assassinated. Robert Kennedy is tragically assassinated. But literally in the middle of all of that chaos and tragedy on the 10th of October, 1968, LBJ placed a call from the Oval Office to Gordon Bunchaft, who was the architect he'd chosen to design his library. Gordon, yes. London Johnson. Oh, yes.
当然，你有超过50万美军在越南。马丁·路德·金当然被悲剧性地暗杀了。罗伯特·肯尼迪被悲剧性地暗杀了。但就在所有这些混乱和悲剧的中间，1968年10月10日，林登·约翰逊从椭圆形办公室给戈登·邦沙夫特打了一个电话，他是他选择设计图书馆的建筑师。戈登，是的。林登·约翰逊。哦，是的。
How are you? I hope I'm not interrupting your dinner. No, no, we've done this in the past. Oh, he was definitely interrupting his dinner. I feel like without a doubt, knowing LBJ, he probably was interrupting his dinner on purpose. Just to show his dominance. Yeah. Yeah, exactly. And what LBJ is calling about is that he had won and he is now wanting one too. But remember the construction of this building is already underway. Now looking at these libraries, is there no way in the world that we could reconstitute
你好吗？希望我没有打扰你的晚餐。不，不，我们过去也这样做过。哦，他绝对是在打扰他的晚餐。我觉得毫无疑问，了解林登·约翰逊的人都知道，他很可能是故意打扰他的晚餐。只是为了展示他的统治力。是的。是的，没错。林登·约翰逊打电话是因为他赢了，现在他也想要一个。但请记住，这座建筑的施工已经在进行中了。现在看着这些图书馆，难道世界上没有办法重建吗？
as nearly as possible. The president's office here. Well, we haven't thought of it, but it's possible. And, you know, listening to this call, the architect clearly wasn't a huge fan of this idea, but the call goes on for seven minutes and forty-six seconds. It's a classic LBJ monologue. I don't have that and anything else about the building. I gather that all right and we'll see. I'm in there now. I'm in that office tonight.
尽可能地。总统的办公室在这里。嗯，我们没想过，但这是可能的。而且，你知道，听这个电话，建筑师显然不是这个想法的忠实粉丝，但电话持续了七分四十六秒。这是一个经典的林登·约翰逊独白。我没有那个，也没有关于建筑的其他任何东西。我明白了，好吧，我们会看到的。我现在就在那里。今晚我在那个办公室里。
I come in at sometimes at 6.30 in the morning and I'm here to late. And I would like for them to see just where we work. And I'd like to have the exact replica as near as possible. But I would accept anything. This is fascinating to me. I mean, this is psychologically, I can't quite parse this. Does he imagine not being president someday
我有时早上6点半就进来了，我在这里待到很晚。我希望他们能看到我们工作的地方。我希望能有一个尽可能精确的复制品。但我会接受任何东西。这对我来说太迷人了。我的意思是，从心理学上讲，我无法完全解析这一点。他是否想象着有一天不再担任总统
and just sitting in his little play set of the presidency in his library? It's just like, it's so odd. I know, I know. And it's just, there's so much president stuff he should be doing. And I'm sure he is doing. I'm sure he is doing.
然后只是坐在他图书馆里的小小总统游戏室里？这真是太奇怪了。我知道，我知道。而且还有很多他应该做的总统事务。我相信他正在做。我相信他正在做。
But he has the space to also be sort of micromanaging the designs of his presidential library. It's very fascinating. the designs of his presidential library, it's very fascinating. So by the late 1960s, early 1970s, every president since FDR had built himself one of these sweet new libraries, and actually Herbert Hoover had built one too retroactively. The libraries were becoming increasingly monumental and grandiose. But interestingly, at this time, the papers of the president were still considered his personal property. Whoa! Okay, that is really strange. So there was like this new custom where, you know,
但他有空间去微观管理他总统图书馆的设计。这非常迷人。所以到了20世纪60年代末、70年代初，自富兰克林·罗斯福以来的每一位总统都为自己建造了这些漂亮的新图书馆，实际上赫伯特·胡佛也追溯性地建造了一个。图书馆变得越来越宏伟和壮观。但有趣的是，在当时，总统的文件仍然被认为是他的个人财产。哇！好吧，这真的很奇怪。所以有一种新的习俗，你知道，
presidents would voluntarily put their papers in the library, and then some of that management we passed over to the National Archives. But it was basically like the honor system, like they didn't have to give everything up, they could just pick a choose. Yeah, yeah, it was the honor system. And can you guess which president really tested that honor system?
总统会自愿把他们的文件放在图书馆里，然后一些管理权会移交给国家档案馆。但这基本上就像荣誉制度，就像他们不必交出所有东西，他们可以挑挑拣拣。是的，是的，这是荣誉制度。你能猜出哪位总统真正考验了那个荣誉制度吗？
Any guesses? I think I can get it in one. We're talking about Richard Millhouse Nixon here. Yeah, the Nixon era was kind of the battle royale over who gets to control the papers of the president. You know, Nixon had proceeded as everyone before him had done as if all the records created by his office during his presidency were his private property and he could do with them as he wished, he could call them, he could destroy them. And Nixon did not foresee that his records would be requested and then demanded by Congress during the investigation into his administration. And when that request and demand was made, you know, he resisted it. And so Congress sees President Nixon's records
有什么猜测吗？我想我能猜到。我们说的是理查德·米尔豪斯·尼克松。是的，尼克松时代是关于谁能控制总统文件的“大逃杀”。你知道，尼克松像他之前的所有人一样行事，仿佛他在总统任期内办公室创建的所有记录都是他的私有财产，他可以随心所欲地处理它们，他可以挑选，他可以销毁它们。而尼克松没有预见到他的记录会在对他政府的调查期间被国会要求并随后被索要。当那个要求和索要被提出时，你知道，他抵制了。所以国会查封了尼克松总统的记录
and subsequently made future presidential records the property of the country rather than the property of the individual president. And they did that with the Presidential Records Act, which passed in 1978. And the PRA says that presidential records are in the public domain, and the public can see them after five years, five years after the president leaves office, with the exception of classified material.
并随后使未来的总统记录成为国家的财产，而不是个人总统的财产。他们通过1978年通过的《总统记录法》做到了这一点。《总统记录法》规定总统记录属于公共领域，公众可以在总统离任五年后查看它们，机密材料除外。
Huh. Well, we're finally getting to where, the way I would expect things to be. So the law affirmed the importance of keeping presidential records safe and available to the public. Yeah, so the law did do that, but the records continued to be stored in presidential libraries. And nothing really changed about the basically self-congratulatory vibe of most of those libraries. The Nixon library is a fascinating example.
嗯。好吧，我们终于到了我所期望的状态。所以法律肯定了保持总统记录安全并对公众开放的重要性。是的，法律确实做到了这一点，但记录继续存储在总统图书馆中。大多数图书馆那种基本上自我吹捧的氛围并没有真正改变。尼克松图书馆就是一个迷人的例子。
For many years, the Nixon Library was actually privately run by the Richard Nixon Foundation. It was not affiliated with the National Archive. And Ipportrade Watergate very much from Nixon's perspective. The event was characterized as a quote unquote coup by Nixon's enemies. Wow.
多年来，尼克松图书馆实际上是由理查德·尼克松基金会私下运营的。它不隶属于国家档案馆。它非常从尼克松的角度描绘了水门事件。该事件被描述为尼克松敌人的所谓“政变”。哇。
And the exhibit suggested that the press had behaved unethically in pursuing the story of his crimes. Wow. That's bold. I know. Yeah. And it wasn't until the mid 2000s that the National Archives came in and took over the museum. And when they did, they insisted that a very well-respected historian come in to create a more factually accurate
展览暗示媒体在追查他的犯罪故事时表现得不道德。哇。这很大胆。我知道。是的。直到21世纪中期，国家档案馆才介入并接管了博物馆。当他们这样做时，他们坚持要求一位备受尊敬的历史学家进来，以创建一个更符合事实的
watergate exhibit. And you can probably imagine members of the Richard Nixon Foundation did not like that. There was one guy who called the New Exhibit a hit piece and the historian involved with it, he was harassed, he eventually resigned. Whoa, okay, that's intense. Yeah, and it's just, you know, it's an example of how structurally it's very hard to tell a nuanced and complex story in these libraries.
水门事件展览。你可能可以想象理查德·尼克松基金会的成员不喜欢那样。有一个人称新展览为“攻击性作品”，参与其中的历史学家受到了骚扰，最终辞职了。哇，好吧，这太激烈了。是的，这只是一个例子，说明在这些图书馆中讲述一个细致入微且复杂的故事在结构上是多么困难。
The president gets to select the architect that they want. They have a role often in selecting who's going to be the director of that presidential library. And the president takes an active role in designing. They're basically the head curator of their museum to themselves. I should say that I talked to various employees of the presidential library system, and I'd ask them, why don't you insist on more historical objectivity?
总统可以选择他们想要的建筑师。他们通常在选择谁将成为该总统图书馆馆长方面发挥作用。总统在设计中发挥积极作用。他们基本上是自己博物馆的首席策展人。我应该说，我采访了总统图书馆系统的各种员工，我问他们，为什么你们不坚持更多的历史客观性？
And some of these people looked at me and said, what plan are you living on? These people have run the country. Do you think we can tell them what to do? What, how do you think that's going to happen? And one of the most compelling examples of this that was described to me was from the decision points theater at the George W. Bush Library in Dallas. Welcome to the decision points theater.
其中一些人看着我说，你生活在哪个星球上？这些人治理过国家。你认为我们可以告诉他们该怎么做吗？什么，你认为这怎么可能发生？我被描述的最引人注目的例子之一来自达拉斯乔治·W·布什图书馆的“决策点剧院”。欢迎来到决策点剧院。
George W. Bush made many tough decisions as present. Now you'll get a flavor for what that's like. Take a look at the list of scenarios in front of you. First. Okay, so the whole decision points experience is very interactive. You get to choose from a menu of scenarios. You can decide what to do in New Orleans after Hurricane Katrina. You can decide what to do following the 2008 financial crisis. You can decide if you want to invade a rack.
乔治·W·布什作为总统做出了许多艰难的决定。现在你将体验一下那是什么感觉。看看你面前的场景列表。第一。好吧，整个决策点体验是非常互动的。你可以从场景菜单中进行选择。你可以决定卡特里娜飓风后在纽奥良做什么。你可以决定在2008年金融危机后做什么。你可以决定是否要入侵伊拉克。
You'll get a briefing, your expert policy advice, and vote on what to do. The experts who are not at the moment are not. That's amazing. I'm very eager to hear how the counterfactuals are written to justify each of the decisions that George W. Bush actually made. Yes. Yeah, it's really interesting because it's genuinely interactive. The audience in this theater gets to vote. And, you know, not surprisingly, in the case of the Iraq War, a fair number of people select no. I do not want to invade Iraq because we're living in the present moment. We know how that went. But if you choose no, President George Bush comes up on the video and says no, that's the incorrect choice.
你会得到简报、专家政策建议，并投票决定做什么。那些专家现在不在现场。这太棒了。我很渴望听到那些反事实是如何被编写出来以证明乔治·W·布什实际做出的每一个决定是合理的。是的。是的，这真的很有趣，因为它是真正互动的。剧院里的观众可以投票。而且，不出所料，在伊拉克战争的情况下，相当多的人选择了“不”。我不希望入侵伊拉克，因为我们生活在当下。我们知道结果如何。但如果你选择“不”，乔治·布什总统会出现在视频中说，不，那是错误的选择。
You must, you know, basically we had no choice. Saddam Hussein represented two big of threat and you must invade Iraq. So the president comes on to scold you about your poor decision making skills that didn't conform to his own. Oh, that's amazing. Yeah, and I guess it shouldn't be that surprising to anyone at this point that we don't get a more nuanced take in a museum designed in close collaboration with Bush himself, but you know it's still problematic. So this is what's troubling about this is that this is a museum run by the federal government. So you think this is the national archives. They're
你必须，你知道，基本上我们别无选择。萨达姆·侯赛因构成的威胁太大，你必须入侵伊拉克。所以总统出现来责骂你糟糕的决策能力，因为它们不符合他自己的决策。哦，这太棒了。是的，我想现在对任何人来说，我们在一个与布什本人密切合作设计的博物馆里得不到更细致的看法，这不应该让人感到惊讶，但你知道这仍然是有问题的。所以这就是令人不安的地方，因为这是一个由联邦政府运营的博物馆。所以你认为这是国家档案馆。他们
not going to feed me something that's a lie or wrong and yet you know from former president Bush's point of view, this is the truth, but it's a very particular and propicandistic truth. I mean, that is really interesting. Like, it's almost less problematic, less official, we try to make these things. You know, like, I would almost have no problem if the Bush family kept, you know, like, a shrine to Bush, but it's almost the fact that it's a government facility. That's the issue. Yeah, yeah.
不会给我喂一些谎言或错误的东西，然而你知道，从布什前总统的角度来看，这是事实，但这是一种非常特殊且具有宣传性质的事实。我的意思是，这真的很有趣。就像，我们试图让这些东西变得不那么有问题，不那么正式。你知道，如果布什家族保留一个布什圣殿，我几乎没有意见，但它是一个政府设施，这才是问题所在。是的，是的。
I think it is the mixing of purposes that makes these institutions so troublesome. You know, it's the way there's an archive that gives legitimacy to the museum, which tells the story in a way that an actual historian never would, sort of lacking all the nuance and complexity that's required. So there's another element to this story, which I talked with Jolapor about. And it has to do with some of the unintended consequences of the Presidential Records Act,
我认为正是目的的混合使得这些机构如此麻烦。你知道，档案馆赋予了博物馆合法性，而博物馆以一种真正的历史学家永远不会采用的方式讲述故事，缺乏所需的细微差别和复杂性。所以这个故事还有另一个要素，我和吉尔·莱波雷谈过。它与《总统记录法》的一些意想不到的后果有关，
which passed right after the Watergate scandal. And of course, it was intended to create a fuller record of each presidency. But she says that in some ways the opposite has happened. Where people say, yeah, well, I would have put it down in a note, but then that would have been subject to the Presidential Records Act. So, you know, I just called the guy. No. So it's like in that sense, it's easy to evade. From historians vantage, these people all used to keep diaries. They're also self-important. Keep endless diaries. And now they don't keep diaries. So you don't even know who they're meeting
该法案在水门事件丑闻后立即通过。当然，它的目的是为每一届总统任期建立更完整的记录。但她说，在某些方面，情况恰恰相反。人们说，是的，好吧，我本可以把它写在便条上，但那样就会受到《总统记录法》的约束。所以，你知道，我只是给那个人打了电话。不。所以从这个意义上说，这很容易规避。从历史学家的角度来看，这些人过去都写日记。他们都很自负。写无休止的日记。而现在他们不写日记了。所以你甚至不知道他们在那一天见了谁
with on a given day, because they didn't want to have that written down. Like people have ways of avoiding creating a record. Yeah, because once you have a record, then some independent council can, you know, like impeach you when you're using those records or lawyers could dig through them. I mean, I could totally see a president just deciding, no, I don't want to deal with that. So did these historians that you talked to have a take on what they thought the future
因为他们不想把这些写下来。就像人们有办法避免创建记录一样。是的，因为一旦你有了记录，那么一些独立检察官就可以，你知道，比如在你使用这些记录时弹劾你，或者律师可以挖掘它们。我的意思是，我完全可以想象一位总统只是决定，不，我不想处理那个。所以你采访的这些历史学家对未来的总统记录有什么看法
presidential records would be like and how they would affect presidential libraries? We did talk about that. And as the power of the presidency has grown over the course of the 20th century, the size of these institutions has grown as well. So that first library that was designed by Roosevelt cost about $7 million in today's money, the latest figures for the construction of the Obama Presidential Center are about 700 million. Oh my God. It's a huge amount of money.
以及它们将如何影响总统图书馆？我们确实谈过那个。随着总统权力的增长，在20世纪的过程中，这些机构的规模也随之增长。所以罗斯福设计的第一座图书馆在今天的货币价值中花费了大约700万美元，奥巴马总统中心建设的最新数字大约是7亿。天哪。这是一笔巨款。
And then at the same time, presidential power has grown. Public trust in the presidency has been falling. I mean, I think there's some public discontent with the idea of the monumentality of these places. I don't think the presidency has the public trust that it had one FDR proposed presidential libraries. I think the presidency has betrayed the public trust that it had, one FDR proposed presidential libraries. I think the presidency has betrayed the public trust.
与此同时，总统权力增长了。公众对总统职位的信任一直在下降。我的意思是，我认为公众对这些地方的纪念碑性质有一些不满。我不认为总统职位拥有富兰克林·罗斯福提议总统图书馆时所拥有的公众信任。我认为总统职位背叛了它所拥有的公众信任，富兰克林·罗斯福提议总统图书馆时。我认为总统职位背叛了公众信任。
And so, Jill Lapor and I think a lot of other professional historians just kind of wish the presidential libraries would go away. Like it's not that their archives aren't important. They truly are. There's no particular reason those collections couldn't be housed in one central place in Washington, DC. Yeah, that certainly makes more sense to me
所以，吉尔·莱波雷和我认为许多其他专业历史学家只是希望总统图书馆消失。就像并不是说它们的档案不重要。它们确实很重要。没有特别的理由说明这些收藏不能存放在华盛顿特区的一个中心地点。是的，这对我来说肯定比把它们分散在全国各地，作为不同男人的不同圣殿更有意义。
than having them sort of spread out around the country and different shrines to different men. Yeah, it makes sense to me too. And interestingly, things might actually be starting to move in that direction. So the Obama Presidential Center, for example, which we were just talking about, it is not going to hold Obama's actual presidential records. Those will be held by the National Archives in various facilities.
是的，这对我来说也很有意义。有趣的是，事情可能真的开始朝着那个方向发展了。所以奥巴马总统中心，例如，我们刚才谈到的，它不会保存奥巴马实际的总统记录。那些将由国家档案馆在各个设施中保存。
The center in Chicago will be the site of the museum and it'll also serve other purposes as a community center as a place for the Obama's philanthropic and diplomatic work. And part of that is because it's just become really expensive for libraries to be affiliated with the National Archives. Over the years, Congress has passed legislation requiring ex-presidents to raise massive endowments that will cover the cost of repairing and maintaining these buildings. So with Trump, there are people who think that if he does manage to build a presidential library,
芝加哥的中心将成为博物馆的所在地，它还将作为社区中心，作为奥巴马夫妇慈善和外交工作的场所，发挥其他作用。部分原因是图书馆隶属于国家档案馆的成本实在太高了。多年来，国会通过了立法，要求前总统筹集巨额捐赠，以支付维修和维护这些建筑的费用。所以对于特朗普，有人认为如果他确实设法建造了一座总统图书馆，
that it might be along the lines of the Obama Center. So he might build a shrine to himself, but people speculate he won't bother with the actual papers. Those will stay with the National Archives. Huh, interesting. So the two purposes that have mixed in such uncomfortable ways through the history of presidential libraries, maybe they're starting to separate now, which seems like a good idea. But that brings us back to the question of the Trump library. And after hearing all this history, I can't imagine any part of that not being filled with Trumpian nonsense. Yeah, I know. And that's what I meant at the beginning when I said that these libraries are all very Trumpian in a way. They all contain evasions and half truths and bluster. And that's what our
它可能会沿着奥巴马中心的方向发展。所以他可能会为自己建造一座圣殿，但人们推测他不会费心去处理实际的文件。那些将留在国家档案馆。嗯，有趣。所以通过总统图书馆历史以如此不舒服的方式混合的两个目的，也许它们现在开始分开了，这似乎是个好主意。但这把我们带回了特朗普图书馆的问题。在听了所有这些历史之后，我无法想象其中任何一部分不充满“特朗普式”的胡言乱语。是的，我知道。这就是我开头说这些图书馆在某种程度上都很“特朗普”的意思。它们都包含逃避、半真半假和虚张声势。这就是我们的
anonymous architect was thinking about too when on election night 2016 he was contemplating the idea of a future Trump library. And what he did is he ended up buying a domain, djTrumpLibrary.com. And he just sat on that domain for a couple years. But then he eventually decided, I am going to design a library that does exactly what none of these real presidential libraries do, which is to really dwell on the bad stuff. Every president has faults. It's a tough job. I don't know why anybody wants a job that jobs and flowers do me. Everybody's yelling at you, no matter how low you do, and 50% country hates you, so you're kind of screwed from death.
匿名建筑师在2016年选举之夜考虑未来特朗普图书馆的想法时所想的。他最终做的是买了一个域名，djTrumpLibrary.com。他坐拥那个域名几年。但后来他最终决定，我要设计一个图书馆，它做的正是所有这些真正的总统图书馆都不做的事情，那就是真正深入探讨坏事。每一位总统都有缺点。这是一份艰难的工作。我不知道为什么有人想要一份工作，工作和鲜花对我来说。每个人都在对你大喊大叫，无论你做得多低，50%的国家都讨厌你，所以你基本上死定了。
But you know what Trump, there was just so much bad and so much scandal. And so this guy designed a parody museum. And if you visit the site, it looks very much like a real presidential library. It's a modern glass box. There's a reflecting pool and various exhibits. But all of the exhibits are sort of fake parody exhibits. There's a Twitter wall, for instance. We had a room about the tax evasion numbers, where he's only paying, I think it was like $750 a year.
但你知道特朗普，那里有太多的坏事和太多的丑闻。所以这家伙设计了一个讽刺博物馆。如果你访问这个网站，它看起来非常像一个真正的总统图书馆。它是一个现代玻璃盒子。有一个倒影池和各种展览。但所有的展览都是某种虚假的讽刺展览。例如，有一个推特墙。我们有一个关于逃税数字的房间，在那里他只支付了，我想是每年750美元。
And then that was the house of room. We had the Aladarks lounge where he showed him kissing up to all the different desks and generally bad people. He likes the Putin's of the world, the Kim Jongles of the world, all these guys, he's BFFs with. Yeah, I'm starting to understand why this guy wanted to remain anonymous.
然后那是那个房间。我们有“阿拉达克斯休息室”，在那里他展示了他向所有不同的桌子和通常的坏人献媚。他喜欢世界上的普京，世界上的金正恩，所有这些家伙，他是他们的死党。是的，我开始明白为什么这家伙想保持匿名了。
Yeah, he just didn't feel entirely safe being public about who designed the site, which actually ended up getting a ton of attention. For a long time, it was the first thing that came up when you Googled Donald Trump Library. I haven't even heard of the official one. Like, this is what I've heard of. It's this fake one.
是的，他只是觉得公开是谁设计了这个网站并不完全安全，这最终引起了极大的关注。很长一段时间里，当你谷歌“唐纳德·特朗普图书馆”时，它是第一个出现的东西。我甚至没听说过官方的那个。就像，这是我听说过的。是这个假的。
Yeah, there's a lot of speculation about what a real one might look like, where it might be, if it will even exist. But the bigger point that this architect wanted to make isn't even necessarily about Trump. It's more just about the way we think about presidents. It's a job. Like, the sooner we get the treating politicians as employees and not as heroes or people that we have to venerate from no good reason. I mean, look, it's an important job and they deserve our respect for your jobs well,
是的，关于一个真正的图书馆可能是什么样子，它可能在哪里，如果它甚至会存在，有很多猜测。但这位建筑师想表达的更重要的观点甚至不一定关于特朗普。它更多是关于我们思考总统的方式。这是一份工作。就像，我们越早把政客当作雇员来对待，而不是当作英雄或我们必须无缘无故崇拜的人。我的意思是，看，这是一份重要的工作，他们理应因为工作出色而得到我们的尊重，
but they're Republican employees. They're replaceable. So I guess in the end, this story is pretty much an episode of what Trump can teach us about presidential libraries. Yeah, it's interesting that it took Trump and before him Nixon to challenge the whole idea of presidential libraries. It's like he's helped expose some of the problems and contradictions that exist in all of them, even for the presidents that I tend to venerate. Right, yeah, it's like there was all this talk during the Trump era about how he exposed so many different institutions and conventions and traditions as inadequate or flawed. And presidential libraries just feel like one more thing
但他们是共和党的雇员。他们是可以被取代的。所以我猜最后，这个故事基本上是“特朗普能教我们关于总统图书馆什么”的一集。是的，有趣的是，直到特朗普，在他之前是尼克松，才挑战了总统图书馆的整个理念。就像他帮助揭露了所有图书馆中存在的一些问题和矛盾，即使是对我倾向于崇拜的总统也是如此。对，是的，就像在特朗普时代，关于他如何揭露如此多不同的机构、惯例和传统是不充分或有缺陷的，有很多讨论。而总统图书馆感觉就像是另一件事
we can see in a new light now. Well, what a weird collection of buildings. Thanks so much for bringing us the story. Sure, thanks, Roman. Coming up after the break, we're going to share a recent episode of What Trump Can Teach Is About Con Law. It's the other podcast I host with Law Professor Elizabeth Jo. It covers the Supreme Court's Shadow Dawkin.
我们现在可以用新的眼光来看待。好吧，真是奇怪的建筑集合。非常感谢你给我们带来这个故事。当然，谢谢，罗曼。休息后，我们将分享一集最近的“特朗普能教我们关于宪法什么”。这是我和法学教授伊丽莎白·乔共同主持的另一个播客。它涵盖了最高法院的“影子案卷”。
Stay tuned. And now an episode of What Trump Can Teach Us About Con Law, released on September 9. Okay, so we're recording this on Monday at 11.45 AM. We're meeting as a sort of special session. So what do you want to talk about today? We're going to talk about legal procedure. I know that sounds really boring, but. But I've learned not from you.
敬请期待。现在是9月9日发布的“特朗普能教我们关于宪法什么”的一集。好吧，我们在周一上午11点45分录制这个节目。我们以一种特别会议的形式会面。所以你今天想谈什么？我们要谈谈法律程序。我知道这听起来很无聊，但是。但我从你那里学到了不是。
We won't be boring from you. But I promise I'm going to show you why it's actually pretty interesting and maybe sometimes just as important or even more important than the right stuff that we talk about. Okay. Cool. So when we think about the US Supreme Court and when it decides important and particularly controversial issues, what we're talking about is what's called its merits docket. Docket just means it's list of legal proceedings. So every year, literally thousands of people who have lost their legal case ask the Supreme Court to hear their case. You know, what's happened here is that somebody has lost a case, could be civil or criminal, and the case started at State Court or Federal Court, and then went up to an appeals court, and then sometimes even to a State Supreme Court.
我们不会从你那里感到无聊。但我保证我会向你展示为什么它实际上非常有趣，也许有时和我们谈论的那些权利问题一样重要，甚至更重要。好吧。酷。所以当我们想到美国最高法院以及它决定重要且特别有争议的问题时，我们谈论的是所谓的“案情案卷”。案卷只是意味着它的法律程序列表。所以每年，确实有成千上万输掉官司的人请求最高法院审理他们的案件。你知道，这里发生的是有人输掉了一场官司，可能是民事或刑事，案件始于州法院或联邦法院，然后上诉到上诉法院，有时甚至到州最高法院。
And so by the time a losing party says, hey, Supreme Court, please hear my case, a lot of courts have already weighed it. They've already said, you know, we've decided against you, or maybe at some level they've said they've decided for you, but at any point, at the time you get to the Supreme Court, you're usually a loser. You want someone to hear your case one last time. Of those thousands of cases, the Supreme Court decides to hear about 60 to 70 a year. So not that many. And when it comes to those kinds of cases, whether we're talking about individual rights or
所以当败诉方说，嘿，最高法院，请审理我的案件时，很多法院已经权衡过了。他们已经说，你知道，我们已经决定反对你，或者也许在某个层面上他们说他们决定支持你，但在你到达最高法院时，你通常是一个失败者。你希望有人最后一次审理你的案件。在成千上万的案件中，最高法院每年决定审理大约60到70个。所以没那么多。当谈到这类案件时，无论我们是在谈论个人权利还是
the power of the federal government to make laws, the Supreme Court has the two sides submit usually two rounds of legal briefs. These are written arguments about why they should win, and then there's an oral argument that's scheduled months in advance. When it comes to really high profile cases, the ones that we all read about in the newspapers, you might also get several amicus or friend of the court briefs. These are legal briefs that are written by the parties who aren't part of the case, but they're telling the Supreme Court, hey, this is such an important issue, please let us weigh in, too. Now, before the pandemic,
联邦政府制定法律的权力，最高法院通常会让双方提交两轮法律摘要。这些是关于他们为何应该胜诉的书面论点，然后是提前数月安排的口头辩论。当涉及到非常引人注目的案件时，也就是我们在报纸上读到的那些案件，你可能还会收到几份法庭之友摘要。这些法律摘要是由不属于该案件的当事人撰写的，但他们是在告诉最高法院，嘿，这是一个非常重要的问题，请也让我们发表意见。现在，在疫情之前，
if you were lucky, you could actually wait in line and get a seat and watch what the justices were going to be asking of the lawyers for both sides. Now during the pandemic, actually kind of lucky in this regard, they went online or sort of online. They went telephonically online. And so we could hear what the justices were asking the different parties during this last term. Eventually, the Supreme Court decides how the case is supposed to come out. There's usually a lengthy written opinion signed by the justice who actually authored the opinion. And we can tell which justices agreed with the majority opinion. And if there are those who didn't agree, well, then you have these dissents, right? The sentencing justice say, well, this is why I think the majority is wrong and we should have done something different.
如果你足够幸运，你实际上可以排队获得一个座位，观看大法官们将要询问双方律师的问题。现在在疫情期间，实际上在这方面有点幸运，他们上网了，或者说是某种程度上的上网。他们通过电话上网了。所以我们可以在上一届会议期间听到大法官们在询问不同当事人什么。最终，最高法院决定案件应该如何结案。通常会有一份冗长的书面意见，由实际撰写该意见的大法官签署。我们可以看出哪些大法官同意多数意见。如果有人不同意，好吧，那么你就有这些异议，对吧？持异议的大法官说，好吧，这就是为什么我认为多数派是错误的，我们应该做些不同的事情。
So that's the Supreme Court we all know and love. The one that we I've just called the Merit Stocket. That's the one where we hear about the the big blockbuster cases. So this whole process like waiting, we usually waiting until the end of the summer to see what the Supreme Court's going to say in a particularly important case. Well, the reason why we have all of this incredible procedure and people weighing in, and there's all this pomp and circumstance, that's kind of the court's legitimacy. They don't just decide, they don't flip a coin, they don't say, hey, we were, you know, voted in by this president, so that's how we're going to decide. They're supposed to say, here's the lengthy legal reasoning behind why we're going to decide. They're supposed to say, here's the lengthy, legal reasoning behind why we're going to go
这就是我们大家都知道和喜爱的最高法院。我刚才称之为“案情摘要案卷”的那一个。那是我们听说那些重磅案件的地方。所以整个过程，比如等待，我们通常等到夏天结束，看看最高法院在一个特别重要的案件中会说什么。好吧，我们之所以有所有这些令人难以置信的程序，人们发表意见，还有所有这些排场和仪式，那算是法院的合法性。他们不仅仅是决定，他们不掷硬币，他们不说，嘿，你知道，我们是由这位总统投票选出的，所以这就是我们要决定的方式。他们应该说，这是我们决定背后的冗长法律推理。他们应该说，这是我们决定背后的冗长法律推理，为什么我们要
ahead and say the case should come out in a particular way. And the idea here is that because we've handed over to the Supreme Court so much power to decide sometimes really life altering decisions in the lives of ordinary people, they owe it to us as the public to explain why they're doing what they're doing But that's not everything the Supreme Court does It also has what's referred to as a non-marit or emotions docket. So Roman have you ever heard of that term? No, no, no Never right and really nobody ever has unless you practice regularly before the Supreme Court
继续说这个案件应该以特定的方式结案。这里的想法是，因为我们已经把决定有时对普通人生活产生改变的决策的权力交给了最高法院，他们有义务向我们公众解释他们为什么这样做。但这并不是最高法院所做的一切。它还有所谓的“非案情摘要案卷”或“动议案卷”。所以罗曼，你听说过这个术语吗？不，不，不，从来没有，对吧？真的没有人听说过，除非你在最高法院经常执业。
You've never heard of this term and you know in the reason why is it's usually pretty boring. Now, the reason why there is a non-marital emotions docket is that the Supreme Court, like any other court, has to issue a lot of orders. Sometimes the parties in the case want to do something kind of boring, like, hey, can we have more time to file a brief? Or sometimes the Supreme Court says, hey, you folks, you wanted an emergency order, there's no emergency here. Or you want us to hear your case, it's just not that important. So for all these kinds of reasons, this non-motions or orders docket never gets any attention.
你从来没有听说过这个术语，你知道原因是因为它通常很无聊。现在，之所以存在非案情摘要或动议案卷，是因为最高法院像任何其他法院一样，必须发布许多命令。有时案件中的当事人想做一些有点无聊的事情，比如，嘿，我们能有更多时间提交摘要吗？或者有时最高法院说，嘿，你们这些人，你们想要一个紧急命令，这里没有紧急情况。或者你们想让我们审理你们的案件，它只是没那么重要。所以由于所有这些原因，这个非动议或命令案卷从来没有得到任何关注。
I shouldn't say never. Very occasionally, you might hear of a death penalty case where there's been a death row inmate facing execution and the Supreme Court in that case might be asked to issue a stay or that's really like a pause of the execution because that person argues that there's some constitutional problem in their case. But again, most of the time the non-merit stock of the Supreme Court is pretty unexciting and really no one's ever heard of it. But in recent years, that boring part of the Supreme Court's work has gotten a lot more interesting, and in ways that a lot of people find alarming.
我不应该说从来没有。非常偶尔地，你可能会听说一个死刑案件，其中有一名死囚面临处决，最高法院在那个案件中可能会被要求发布暂缓执行令，或者那真的就像是暂停执行，因为那个人辩称他们的案件中存在某种宪法问题。但同样，大多数时候，最高法院的非案情摘要案卷是相当乏味的，真的没有人听说过它。但近年来，最高法院工作中那部分无聊的内容变得有趣多了，而且是以许多人感到震惊的方式。
So let's talk about the shadow docket, abortion in Texas, and maybe the state of abortion Let's do it. This is what Trump can teach us about common law, an ongoing series of indefinite length where we take the horrible current events and the ripple effects of the Trump presidency and use them to examine our constitution like we never have before. Our music is from DoomTree Records, our professor and neighbor is Elizabeth Joe and I'm your fellow perpetual student and host Roman Mars. So I've heard this term on Twitter a little bit and I'm here to ask what is a shadow docket? Okay, so the actual term is something coined by a law professor named Will Bode in 2015 to describe what we've just talked about, this idea of an order's docket of the Supreme Court.
所以让我们谈谈影子案卷、德克萨斯州的堕胎，也许还有堕胎的现状。让我们开始吧。这就是特朗普能教给我们关于普通法的东西，这是一个无限期的持续系列，我们利用可怕的时事和特朗普总统任期的连锁反应，以前所未有的方式审视我们的宪法。我们的音乐来自DoomTree Records，我们的教授和邻居是伊丽莎白·乔，我是你们的终身学生和主持人罗曼·马尔斯。所以我已经在推特上听到过这个术语，我在这里问，什么是影子案卷？好的，所以这个实际术语是2015年一位名叫威尔·博德的法学教授创造的，用来描述我们刚才谈到的东西，即最高法院的命令案卷的想法。
Even though the terms coined pretty recently, the Supreme Court's always had this thing, where they just have the issue orders that are related to cases before them. Again, historically pretty boring, no one usually cares about it. But if you're a watcher of the Supreme Court, you've probably noticed that in recent years, the Supreme Court seems to be relying more on the so-called shadow docket to make decisions in high profile cases. So you ask, why is it a shadow docket? What is it? So these are not the ordinary way that the Supreme Court decides cases. There's no extensive rounds of legal briefing. There's no oral arguments by the lawyers. There's no oral argument decided in advance months ahead of time
尽管这个术语是最近才创造出来的，但最高法院一直有这个东西，他们只是发布与他们面前案件相关的命令。同样，历史上相当无聊，通常没人关心它。但如果你是最高法院的观察者，你可能已经注意到，近年来，最高法院似乎更多地依赖所谓的影子案卷来对高调案件做出决定。所以你问，为什么它是影子案卷？它是什么？所以这些不是最高法院决定案件的通常方式。没有广泛的法律摘要环节。没有律师的口头辩论。没有提前数月决定的口头辩论
for all of us to try and figure out if we can attend in person or maybe listen to you online. The Supreme Court might just issue an order. I sometimes there's no legal opinion or there's just a very brief opinion might be one paragraph long. And the courts usually on a really rushed timeline. And sometimes we don't really know which justice wrote the opinion.
供我们所有人尝试弄清楚我们是否可以亲自参加或者也许在线收听。最高法院可能只是发布一个命令。有时没有法律意见，或者只有一个非常简短的意见，可能只有一段长。而且法院通常处于一个非常匆忙的时间表上。有时我们真的不知道是哪位大法官写了这份意见。
And sometimes we don't really know which justice is totally agreed with that unsigned opinion. And they can decide these orders at any time they wish, could be in the middle of the night. So you can see that this is really different than the way that the court normally decides its cases. And that's kind of the problem. It's less transparent, it's less predictable.
有时我们真的不知道是哪位大法官完全同意那份未署名的意见。他们可以在他们希望的任何时间决定这些命令，可能是在半夜。所以你可以看出这与法院通常决定其案件的方式确实不同。这就是问题所在。它透明度较低，可预测性较低。
The parties themselves aren't that much involved in these cases. So the whole idea is that they're just kind of less open overall when it comes to the shadowdocket. And when you have something as important as a Supreme Court, remember, practically speaking, they have the final say on what the Constitution means. That raises issues about their trustworthiness and their legitimacy if they're issuing really big decisions in the middle of the night. And we're not even sure who wrote the thing that makes
当事人本身并没有过多参与这些案件。所以整个想法是，当涉及到影子案卷时，它们总体上不太开放。当你拥有像最高法院这样重要的机构时，记住，实际上，他们对宪法的含义拥有最终决定权。如果他们在半夜发布非常重大的决定，这会引发关于他们的可信度和合法性的问题。我们甚至不确定是谁写了那个产生
such a big impression. So you and I just talked about a shadowdocket case pretty recently, and that was one of the COVID cases. Remember, there was a challenge to the COVID restrictions in New York state. And just as a recap, remember, some religious groups said that the state of New York was treating them more harshly than if you were a non-religious entity when it came to allowing people for indoor gatherings.
如此巨大影响的东西。所以你和我刚才谈到了一个影子案卷案件，那就是新冠疫情案件之一。还记得吗，有人对纽约州的新冠限制措施提出了质疑。作为回顾，记住，一些宗教团体说，当涉及到允许人们进行室内聚会时，纽约州对待他们比对待非宗教实体更严厉。
So the Supreme Court decided in that case, remember that on the midnight before Thanksgiving of last year that, yep, this was an unconstitutional restriction on their religious freedom. That COVID restriction, even though, of course, there was a public health reason behind it, violated their First Amendment religious freedom rights. This is an example of a shadow-docket decision. This wasn't an ordinary case with the world arguments and the briefing. In fact, it was an emergency request by the religious groups and the Supreme Court intervened and said,
所以最高法院在那个案件中决定，记住在去年感恩节前的午夜，是的，这是对他们宗教自由的违宪限制。那个新冠限制，尽管当然背后有公共卫生原因，但违反了他们第一修正案的宗教自由权利。这是一个影子案卷决定的例子。这不是一个有口头辩论和摘要的普通案件。事实上，这是宗教团体的紧急请求，最高法院进行了干预并说，
oh, you can't do this, New York. That was a five-four opinion. It was unsigned. We know the vote in this particular case because there were four justices who dissented, including the Chief Justice John Roberts. There are plenty of other examples too. Do you remember the eviction moratorium that
哦，你不能这样做，纽约。那是一个五比四的意见。它是未署名的。我们知道这个特定案件的投票结果，因为有四位大法官持异议，包括首席大法官约翰·罗伯茨。还有很多其他的例子。你还记得驱逐暂停令吗？
Congress imposed at the really part of the pandemic? Sure. You have this idea where Congress stopped evictions as part of the second COVID relief act. The idea here is, of course, if you have mass unemployment because of COVID, that leads to people being homeless. And maybe that would make the pandemic even worse. When Congress decides to impose this moratorium, it was supposed to last just 120 days.
国会在疫情初期实施的？当然。你有这样一个想法，即国会作为第二次新冠救济法案的一部分停止了驱逐。这里的想法当然是，如果你因为新冠而有大规模失业，那会导致人们无家可归。也许那会让疫情变得更糟。当国会决定实施这个暂停令时，它本应只持续120天。
And Congress decides not to renew it. But the Centers for Disease Control, CDC, was concerned that, well, maybe there still should be an eviction moratorium. So they decide on their own to extend the moratorium a couple of times. So that CDC moratorium was challenged in federal court. A federal judge agreed that, well, maybe the CDC doesn't have the authority to do this,
而国会决定不续期。但疾病控制与预防中心（CDC）担心，好吧，也许仍然应该有一个驱逐暂停令。所以他们决定自己几次延长暂停令。所以那个CDC暂停令在联邦法院受到了挑战。一位联邦法官同意，好吧，也许CDC没有权力这样做，
but we'll put a pause on this decision while the parties appeal. So, eventually, this goes up as another emergency decision to the Supreme Court. So, remember, when you think about the importance of an eviction moratorium, what's the public interest here, do you think? Yeah, or it's like the public interest is really high because it's a matter of life and death if you have a home or not. Exactly. And it's something that potentially affects hundreds of thousands of people, right? People who are just on the brink of eviction. So when you think about just in terms of like ordinary
但我们会在当事人上诉时暂停这个决定。所以，最终，这作为另一个紧急决定提交给了最高法院。所以，记住，当你考虑驱逐暂停令的重要性时，你认为这里的公共利益是什么？是的，或者就像公共利益非常高，因为如果你是否有家是一个生死攸关的问题。完全正确。而且这可能影响成千上万的人，对吧？那些正处于驱逐边缘的人。所以当你考虑就像普通
folks, ordinary Americans being affected by this, this kind of feels like case that normally, shouldn't it be part of the court's normal case load? We have briefs, you have a normal argument, maybe you accept that doesn't in front of the court briefs. Maybe there should be a really lengthy opinion about a really big question, you know, kind of federal agency that's responsible for stopping communicable diseases. Can they have an eviction moratorium as one of those measures during a global unprecedented pandemic.
人，普通美国人受到这个影响时，这感觉就像是一个案件，通常情况下，它不应该成为法院正常案件量的一部分吗？我们有摘要，你有正常的辩论，也许你接受法庭之友摘要。也许应该有一份关于一个非常大问题的冗长意见，你知道，某种负责停止传染病的联邦机构。他们能在全球前所未有的疫情期间将驱逐暂停令作为这些措施之一吗？
But instead, this is a shadowdocket case. So on August 26, the court issued an opinion, a short one, eight pages, its own sign. They say, no, the CDC can't do this. And so no more eviction moratorium. Justice Breyer wrote a dissenting opinion, not just about the substance of the decision, but the procedure. He says, these questions call for considered decision-making, informed by full briefing and argument. Their answers impact the health of millions. We should not set aside the CDC's eviction moratorium
但相反，这是一个影子案卷案件。所以8月26日，法院发布了一份意见，一份简短的，八页，它未署名。他们说，不，CDC不能这样做。所以没有更多的驱逐暂停令。布雷耶大法官写了一份异议意见，不仅是关于决定的实质，而且是关于程序。他说，这些问题需要经过深思熟虑的决策，并由充分的摘要和辩论提供信息。它们的答案影响着数百万人的健康。我们不应该在这个简易程序中搁置CDC的驱逐暂停令。
in this summary proceeding. So Breyer is really saying, I don't like this and I also don't like the way we're doing this. We need to have this in a regular transparent open way that we do with our other really big cases. So this is a roundabout way of getting to the more recent news, and that is the Texas law, right? SBA. So let's talk about that. In May, the governor of Texas Greg Abbott, he signs SBA into law. The law is actually pretty similar to a number of other state abortion laws that are called heartbeat laws.
所以布雷耶真的在说，我不喜欢这个，我也不喜欢我们这样做的方式。我们需要以我们处理其他非常大案件的那种常规、透明、开放的方式来处理这个问题。所以这是通往最近新闻的迂回方式，那就是德克萨斯州的法律，对吧？SB8。所以让我们谈谈那个。5月，德克萨斯州州长格雷格·阿博特签署了SB8成为法律。该法律实际上与其他一些被称为“心跳法”的州堕胎法非常相似。
So basically, this new law says that women in Texas can obtain a legal abortion when you can detect a fetal heartbeat, which is around six weeks of pregnancy. But six weeks just means that almost all abortions are banned because at six weeks many women have no idea that they're pregnant. So if I say, like other states have done this before, well, it also means that other states, when they've had such laws, they've been challenged in court. And they've generally been struck down
所以基本上，这项新法律规定，当你可以检测到胎儿心跳时，德克萨斯州的女性可以获得合法堕胎，这大约是在怀孕六周时。但六周只意味着几乎所有的堕胎都被禁止了，因为在六周时，许多女性根本不知道自己怀孕了。所以如果我说，像其他州以前做过的那样，好吧，这也意味着其他州，当他们有这样的法律时，它们在法庭上受到了挑战。而且它们通常被推翻了，
because these laws violate a woman's constitutional rights. You and I've talked a couple of times about Roe versus Wade and how the Supreme Court has interpreted what the states can do. But just as a refresher, remember, states are not allowed to completely ban abortion before what's called fetal viability. That means the stage when a fetus can live outside of the womb. That's why previous six-week bans are easily struck down. Six weeks is way, way, way, before the point of viability. Okay, so SBA, the Texas law though is different in kind of a devious and dastardly way.
因为这些法律违反了女性的宪法权利。你和我谈过几次罗诉韦德案，以及最高法院如何解释各州可以做什么。但作为一个回顾，记住，各州不允许在所谓的胎儿存活能力之前完全禁止堕胎。这意味着胎儿可以在子宫外生存的阶段。这就是为什么以前的六周禁令很容易被推翻。六周远在存活点之前。好的，所以SB8，德克萨斯州的法律虽然在某种阴险和卑鄙的方式上是不同的。
We've talked about Roe v Wade before, and the story behind Jane Roe, who was later identified as Norma McCorvey, now let's look at it in a different way. The case is called Roe v Wade, right? We spent a lot of time talking about Jane Roe. Well, who's Wade? Part of thinking about this is thinking about how the law challenged in row, what it was, and how it was challenged. So in row itself, one of the laws that was challenged made it a crime to procure an abortion. So, Roman, if something's
我们之前谈过罗诉韦德案，以及简·罗背后的故事，她后来被确认为诺玛·麦考维，现在让我们以不同的方式来看待它。这个案件被称为罗诉韦德案，对吧？我们花了很多时间谈论简·罗。好吧，谁是韦德？思考这个问题的一部分是思考罗案中挑战的法律是什么，以及它是如何被挑战的。所以在罗案本身中，被挑战的法律之一规定获取堕胎是犯罪。所以，罗曼，如果某事是
a crime, who enforces the law? That's right. So at the time of the law of the challenge, Jane Roe was living in Dallas County, Texas. And Wade is Henry Wade. He was the district attorney of Dallas County. So in other words, the person who in theory would be responsible for prosecuting violations of a criminal abortion statute. So that's the way. That's the other party in the case who normally doesn't get any attention at all.
犯罪，谁执行法律？那是对的。所以在挑战法律时，简·罗住在德克萨斯州达拉斯县。而韦德是亨利·韦德。他是达拉斯县的地方检察官。所以换句话说，理论上负责起诉违反刑事堕胎法规的人。所以这就是韦德。那是案件中的另一方，通常根本得不到任何关注。
But this way, this procedure, the way the law is challenged, is pretty typical of a lot of lawsuits when it comes to constitutional rights. Someone sues, because they argue that a law violates their rights under the Constitution. And in order to do that, they often sue the person who's responsible for enforcing the law. So if a court agrees that the law is unconstitutional, they're also deciding that that government official, so Henry Wade and Roe v Wade, who's standing in for all the other government officials,
但这种方式，这个程序，法律被挑战的方式，在涉及到宪法权利时，对于许多诉讼来说是相当典型的。有人起诉，因为他们辩称法律违反了他们在宪法下的权利。为了做到这一点，他们经常起诉负责执行法律的人。所以如果法院同意法律是违宪的，他们也决定了那位政府官员，所以亨利·韦德和罗诉韦德案中代表所有其他政府官员的人，
can't enforce an unconstitutional law. Okay, so Texas. But Texas's law is different. The Texas law actually forbids the state's government officials from enforcing the law. And instead, the law gives everybody else any private person the ability to sue. But what can they sue for in this case? Okay, so the first part maybe makes sense. They can sue anybody who performs an abortion, but there's more. You can also sue as a private individual, anyone who aids or abets an abortion. Aides and are abets is just a legal term for meaning helping.
不能执行违宪的法律。好的，所以德克萨斯州。但德克萨斯州的法律不同。德克萨斯州的法律实际上禁止该州的政府官员执行该法律。相反，该法律赋予其他人，任何私人，起诉的能力。但他们在这个案件中可以起诉什么？好的，所以第一部分可能说得通。他们可以起诉任何进行堕胎的人，但还有更多。你也可以作为私人起诉任何协助或教唆堕胎的人。协助和教唆只是一个法律术语，意思是帮助。
So anybody who helps, but there's also more. You can also sue anybody who intends to aid or a bet an abortion or intends to perform an abortion. So that really means that because of SB8, which is structured in this really different way, you can sue an abortion provider, but you can also sue a friend or a family member, maybe who helped pay for your abortion.
所以任何帮助的人，但还有更多。你也可以起诉任何打算协助或教唆堕胎或打算进行堕胎的人。所以这真的意味着，因为SB8是以这种非常不同的方式构建的，你可以起诉堕胎提供者，但你也可以起诉朋友或家人，也许是那些帮助支付你堕胎费用的人。
Maybe the Uber driver who drove you to the abortion services provider. Maybe your friend or family member who decided to drive you there on their own provided some source of support. So this is how this particular law, SBA, makes it really different in terms of raising a constitutional challenge.
也许是开车送你去堕胎服务提供者的优步司机。也许是你的朋友或家人，他们决定自己开车送你去那里，提供了一些支持来源。所以这就是这项特定法律SB8在提出宪法挑战方面如何使它变得非常不同。
So my question is, who would be the hypothetical person suing here? And why would they have standing to sue in this case? In any case. Right, so standing in terms of what the federal courts do comes from restrictions on the Constitution, but this is a state law. And states can define standing in different and sometimes wider ways. So it's a little bit unclear right now,
所以我的问题是，谁会是这里起诉的假设人？为什么他们在这个案件中有起诉资格？在任何案件中。对，所以就联邦法院所做的而言，起诉资格来自宪法的限制，但这是一项州法律。各州可以以不同且有时更广泛的方式定义起诉资格。所以现在有点不清楚，
but it looks like Texas can allow citizens to have this kind of broad standing in ways that federal courts can't. But to get to your more specific question, who can sue pretty much anybody? You don't have to be a person in Texas. You can be presumably anybody on the planet. You just have to sue in a Texas court. Yeah, but then sue for what? For the existence of abortion services or sue for who? Like I get that it can be anybody you mentioned, anybody in the process. So I could just randomly pick out a person who got an abortion and then sue all the people that were involved in it. Like just me as a person.
但看起来德克萨斯州可以允许公民以联邦法院无法做到的方式拥有这种广泛的起诉资格。但要回答你更具体的问题，谁可以起诉？几乎任何人。你不必是德克萨斯州的人。你大概可以是地球上的任何人。你只需要在德克萨斯州的法院起诉。是的，但然后起诉什么？为了堕胎服务的存在还是起诉谁？就像我明白它可以是你提到的任何人，过程中的任何人。所以我可以随便挑一个堕胎的人，然后起诉所有参与其中的人。就像我作为一个普通人。
That seems to be the way it works. So basically the state of Texas has shifted enforcement from normally the way a crime works you'd have again, the district attorneys involved in prosecution. This isn't a crime. This is basically handing over enforcement civilly to everybody else except people who normally enforce criminal laws.
这似乎就是它的工作方式。所以基本上德克萨斯州已经将执法从通常犯罪的工作方式转移了，你会再次有地方检察官参与起诉。这不是犯罪。这基本上是将执法权民事移交给除通常执行刑事法律的人以外的所有人。
It does so by incentivizing these civil suits. If you sue and win, let's say you sue an abortion services provider, you sue someone who helped a woman obtain an abortion, you get to collect a minimum of $10,000 and attorney's fees for each abortion. Wow. And bizarrely under the law, if you bring that lawsuit and lose, nothing happens to you. It's not only a penalty or anything. Oh my god. So presumably, the result of this is every anti-abortion organization in the world could just begin suing. As long as they have like the facts of an abortion that has happened, they could just begin
它通过激励这些民事诉讼来做到这一点。如果你起诉并胜诉，假设你起诉了一家堕胎服务提供者，你起诉了一个帮助女性获得堕胎的人，你每次堕胎可以获得至少10,000美元和律师费。哇。而且奇怪的是，根据法律，如果你提起该诉讼并败诉，你不会发生任何事情。这甚至不是惩罚什么的。哦，我的天。所以大概，结果是世界上每个反堕胎组织都可以开始起诉。只要他们有已经发生的堕胎的事实，他们就可以开始
suing every part of the chain of provider, including the lift driver out of existence. That's what it sounds like. I mean, the law has just gone into effect as of September 1st, so we don't really know how it's going to work out, but the financial incentive does feel like bounty hunting. The whole scheme feels like kind of like legal trolling. You can just harass nearly anybody who is somehow connected with an abortion. If you're an abortion services provider, you either close down or you face a flood of civil lawsuits.
起诉链条中的每一部分提供者，包括那个优步司机，直到他们破产。听起来就是这样。我的意思是，法律自9月1日起刚刚生效，所以我们真的不知道它会如何发展，但经济激励确实感觉像赏金猎人。整个计划感觉就像某种法律钓鱼。你可以骚扰几乎任何与堕胎有某种联系的人。如果你是一家堕胎服务提供者，你要么关闭，要么面临大量的民事诉讼。
And if you're an ordinary person who might formally in Texas have been happy to help a friend or a family member, I think you're certainly deterred from doing so. I mean, $10,000 is a lot of money, right? $10,000 is a lot to be liable for. So after the law is enacted, a group of abortion services providers in Texas then file the lawsuit, because that's not surprising.
如果你是一个普通人，在德克萨斯州可能曾经乐于帮助朋友或家人，我想你肯定会被阻止这样做。我的意思是，10,000美元是一大笔钱，对吧？10,000美元是很大的责任。所以法律颁布后，德克萨斯州的一群堕胎服务提供者随后提起了诉讼，因为这并不令人惊讶。
They filed a lawsuit in federal court in July to try and stop the law from taking effect, which was designed to go into effect on September 1st. So Roman, we did talk about how SBA is different than say the law that was challenged in Roe V. Wade. So can you see the problem here with the lawsuit? Well, there's no Wade. Right. There's no Wade. Who, there's no Wade.
他们在7月向联邦法院提起诉讼，试图阻止该法律生效，该法律旨在9月1日生效。所以罗曼，我们确实谈到了SB8与罗诉韦德案中挑战的法律有何不同。所以你能看出这里的诉讼有什么问题吗？好吧，没有韦德。对。没有韦德。谁，没有韦德。
Who do you sue? So that's a bit of a problem. So in this particular lawsuit, they sue state judge, a clerk on behalf of a whole class of state judges and clerks and a private individual who is presumably anti-abortion. Now, remember, you just said there's no Wade because they can't sue a Wade because they can't sue a
你起诉谁？所以那有点问题。所以在这个特定的诉讼中，他们起诉了一名州法官、一名代表全体州法官和书记员的书记员，以及一名大概是反堕胎的私人。现在，记住，你刚才说没有韦德，因为他们不能起诉韦德，因为他们不能起诉一个
Wade. They can't sue a district attorney or any other state executive official in Texas because the law actually says you know these government officials aren't responsible for enforcing this law everybody else is. So usually when you have a state law where the state's officials are responsible for enforcing it it's normal to have a lawsuit filed against them even before it takes effect. But this law is really strange and intentionally so. So in any event, because of this weird aspect of SBA, there's a lot of procedural back and forth in this case, which gets pretty complicated. But what's important here is that eventually the abortion services providers end up at the Supreme Court.
韦德。他们不能起诉德克萨斯州的地方检察官或任何其他州行政官员，因为法律实际上说你知道这些政府官员不负责执行这项法律，其他人负责。所以通常当你有一项州法律，州官员负责执行它时，在它生效之前对他们提起诉讼是很正常的。但这项法律真的很奇怪，而且是故意这样设计的。所以无论如何，由于SB8的这个奇怪方面，这个案件中有很多程序上的来回，这变得相当复杂。但这里重要的是，最终堕胎服务提供者来到了最高法院。
They ask for an emergency order to stop the law from taking effect. So in other words, it's not a normal, so-called merit's case. The Supreme Court has not granted full review of this case. Of course, that means there's no oral argument, there aren't any multiple rounds of briefing, there's no dozens of front of the court briefs, there's just no regular procedure for reviewing what happens to be a pretty complicated law raising complicated issues. So what happens next is exactly what people are increasingly worried about with the so-called shadow docket. On September 1st, just before midnight,
他们要求紧急命令以阻止法律生效。所以换句话说，这不是一个正常的，所谓的案情摘要案件。最高法院没有批准对该案件进行全面审查。当然，这意味着没有口头辩论，没有任何多轮摘要，没有几十份法庭之友摘要，对于审查恰好是一个提出复杂问题的复杂法律来说，根本没有常规程序。所以接下来发生的事情正是人们越来越担心所谓的影子案卷的事情。9月1日，午夜前夕，
the Supreme Court in a five-four ruling refuses to step in in the case of whole women's health versus Jackson. There is basically one unsigned paragraph. They say, we're not saying whether the law's constitutional or not, but there's just too many procedural issues right now for us to want to step in and do anything. But remember how I told you that procedure sometimes can be pretty exciting? Well, this is an example.
最高法院以五比四的裁决拒绝在“全女性健康诉杰克逊”一案中介入。基本上只有一个未署名的段落。他们说，我们不是在说法律是否违宪，但现在有太多的程序问题，我们不想介入并做任何事情。但还记得我告诉过你程序有时会非常令人兴奋吗？好吧，这是一个例子。
So this procedural decision actually has a practical effect. The Supreme Court isn't saying here that we're overturning Roe versus Wade throughout the country or in Texas, if that were a thing. But the effect of their decision means that in Texas, abortion is pretty much de facto illegal. You can't get an abortion because now SBA is the law, at least in Texas. So until and unless there's a challenge that successfully makes its way up to the Supreme Court,
所以这个程序性决定实际上产生了实际效果。最高法院在这里并不是说我们正在推翻全国或德克萨斯州的罗诉韦德案，如果那是真的话。但他们决定的效果意味着在德克萨斯州，堕胎几乎是事实上的非法。你不能堕胎，因为现在SB8是法律，至少在德克萨斯州是这样。所以除非有一个挑战成功地一路提交到最高法院，
that's what the law is in Texas itself. Chief Justice Roberts, along with the three liberal justices dissent in this case, and I'll just focus on one of the dissents, Justice Sotomayor's, because the opening of her dissent is worth quoting. She says, the court's order is stunning, She says, the court's order is stunning, presented with an application to enjoy a flagrantly unconstitutional law engineered to prohibit women from exercising their constitutional rights and evade judicial scrutiny. A majority of justices have opted to bury their heads
这就是德克萨斯州本身的法律。首席大法官罗伯茨与三位自由派大法官在这个案件中持异议，我将只关注其中一份异议，索托马约尔大法官的，因为她异议的开头值得引用。她说，法院的命令令人震惊，她说，法院的命令令人震惊，面对一份旨在禁止女性行使宪法权利并逃避司法审查的公然违宪法律的申请。多数大法官选择将头埋在
in the sands. And Justice Sotomayor calls the law out for what it is. She says the Texas legislature has deputized the state's citizens as bounty hunters. She's mad. Yeah. She ends her descent by saying, I descent. I note that because normally the justice is say, I respectfully descent. No such thing from Justice Sotomayor this time. So just like that, with this so-called shadow-docked case, SBA is allowed to stay in effect. And so why is it a shadow-docked case? Like, can the justices require it become a sort of merit case? Well, in this particular case, because of the procedural issues,
沙子里。索托马约尔大法官指出了这项法律的本质。她说德克萨斯州立法机构已将该州公民任命为赏金猎人。她很生气。是的。她以“我持异议”结束了她的异议。我注意到这一点，因为通常大法官们会说，“我恭敬地持异议”。这次索托马约尔大法官没有那样说。所以就这样，随着这个所谓的影子案卷案件，SB8被允许保持有效。那么为什么它是一个影子案卷案件？就像，大法官们能要求它成为某种案情摘要案件吗？好吧，在这个特定案件中，由于程序问题，
it hadn't actually been litigated all the way through. Is that a preliminary stage? The fifth circuit just stepped in to stop the district court from putting a pause on things. This is a short way of saying it actually didn't fully mature into the case that the Supreme Court usually votes on to decide whether or not're not going to take it or not. So you could say, well, this is kind of all they could do anyway. But maybe one way of thinking about this shadow-dock-it issue is, well, what is the Supreme Court's supposed to do in a situation like this?
它实际上并没有被完全诉讼到底。那是一个初步阶段吗？第五巡回法院刚刚介入阻止地方法院暂停事情。这是说它实际上并没有完全成熟为最高法院通常投票决定是否要受理的案件的简短方式。所以你可以说，好吧，这已经是他们能做的全部了。但也许思考这个影子案卷问题的一种方式是，好吧，最高法院在这种情况下应该做什么？
Well, maybe they should stop things from going south when there are rights involved and there are potential infringement of rights or they don't get involved ever Because they just should keep the status quo in all kinds of cases when they appear on the shadow docket But the problem is the courts completely inconsistent Right, so you could say that well in this case they didn't do anything, right? And maybe that's a good thing. They're not supposed to do anything in these shadow docket cases But it kind of turns out that it depends on the subject matter because when it comes to religious freedom rights and COVID restrictions, they were all too happy to step in and When it came to the scope of federal power and whether or not you can have an eviction moratorium in a pandemic
好吧，也许当涉及权利且存在潜在的权利侵犯时，他们应该阻止事情恶化，或者他们根本不参与，因为当它们出现在影子案卷上时，他们应该在各种案件中保持现状。但问题是法院完全不一致。对，所以你可以说，好吧，在这个案件中他们什么也没做，对吧？也许那是一件好事。他们不应该在这些影子案卷案件中做任何事情。但事实证明，这取决于主题，因为当涉及到宗教自由权利和新冠限制时，他们非常乐意介入，当涉及到联邦权力的范围以及你是否可以在疫情中实施驱逐暂停令时，
They were all too happy to step in. So this starts to strike people as being more motivated by the topic and what five justices feel about it. Then any consistency and well, we don't step in when we have these kinds of emergency procedures. Oh, it's grim. It is grim. And in fact, you know, one of the things that people are worried about now is that the Supreme Court has already agreed to hear a case in the fall on its normal mirrored stocket that actually is a challenge to a Mississippi law that bans most abortions after 15 weeks of pregnancy. Of course, that's later than the
他们非常乐意介入。所以这开始让人们觉得这更多是受主题和五位大法官对此的感受所驱动。而不是任何一致性，好吧，当我们有这些紧急程序时，我们不介入。哦，这很严峻。这确实很严峻。事实上，你知道，人们现在担心的一件事是，最高法院已经同意在秋季在其正常的案情摘要案卷中审理一个案件，这实际上是对密西西比州一项法律的挑战，该法律禁止在怀孕15周后进行大多数堕胎。当然，那比
Texas law. The case is called DOBS, and it's a law that's pretty clearly intended to be a challenge to Roe v. Wade. Now, you might say that, well, in the Texas case, the Supreme Court refused to step in, but they did technically say, we're not ruling on the constitutionality of the Texas law. That's technically true,
德克萨斯州的法律晚。这个案件被称为多布斯案，这是一项很明显旨在挑战罗诉韦德案的法律。现在，你可能会说，好吧，在德克萨斯州的案件中，最高法院拒绝介入，但他们确实在技术上说，我们不对德克萨斯州法律的合宪性做出裁决。这在技术上是真的，
but it's hard not to interpret what they did as bad news for further cutting back on the rights of women when it comes to abortion and the constitution. Oh. I mean, this tactic of creating a law in which there is no way and passing it through with some knuckleheads and state legislature
但很难不把他们的所作所为解释为在堕胎和宪法方面进一步削减女性权利的坏消息。哦。我的意思是，这种创造一种没有韦德的法律，并让州立法机构中一些
who are not thoughtful about the law at all, is this now a thing? Like did they just pioneer something horrible that's going to happen in all kinds of states? It seems to be right. I mean, it does seem to be a novel way of trying to attack a constitutionally established right in a way that's really hard to challenge, right? As you can see from this particular case, right, the one that we just talked about, these abortion services providers hadn't argument about the constitutionality of SB8, but wasn't really clear who they could sue, because no one had actually sued them yet, right? And it does create an incentive for other states to craft the same kind of version of SBA for their own states, you know, leave it to ordinary private citizens to try and enforce really restrictive right on abortions. And it also creates incentives, I think, for states to pass
根本不考虑法律的笨蛋通过它的策略，这现在是一回事吗？就像他们刚刚开创了某种将在各种州发生的可怕事情吗？看起来确实如此。我的意思是，这似乎是一种试图以一种非常难以挑战的方式攻击宪法确立的权利的新颖方式，对吧？正如你可以从这个特定案件中看到的，对吧，我们刚才谈到的那个，这些堕胎服务提供者对SB8的合宪性有论点，但并不真正清楚他们可以起诉谁，因为还没有人真正起诉他们，对吧？而且它确实为其他州创造了为自己的州制定相同版本的SB8的激励，你知道，让普通私人公民尝试执行非常严格的堕胎权利。而且我认为，它也为各州通过
basically vigilante bounty laws for any kind of subject. So it doesn't have to be just abortion, right? You could imagine a state thinking, sort of offering a, you know, $10,000 cash prize to allow people to sue others when there's some perceived violation of religious rights, free speech rights, you name it. So if we let this go on, there's potentially a snowball effect of really encouraging this sort of structure to pop up elsewhere throughout the United States. Yeah.
基本上针对任何主题的义务警员赏金法律创造了激励。所以它不必只是堕胎，对吧？你可以想象一个州在想，提供某种，你知道，10,000美元的现金奖励，允许人们在感知到宗教权利、言论自由权利等受到侵犯时起诉他人。所以如果我们让这种情况继续下去，可能会产生一种鼓励这种结构在整个美国其他地方出现的滚雪球效应。是的。
And this seems like it's perfectly the purview of the Supreme Court to recognize these as being unconstitutional or constitutional, whatever their decision should be. So what is the process for it to sort of take this case to sort of like make its way up to the Supreme Court for them to be able to make that type of decision or to voice that type of opinion? Yeah, I mean, it's a good question. I think that's less clear. I mean, I think if there is a case that sort of presents squarely the whether or not
这似乎完全是最高法院的职权范围，承认这些是违宪的还是合宪的，无论他们的决定应该是什么。那么它以某种方式提交给最高法院，以便他们能够做出那种决定或表达那种意见的过程是什么？是的，我的意思是，这是一个好问题。我想那不太清楚。我的意思是，我想如果有一个案件以某种方式直接提出了
Texas is abortion law, violates the constitution, and it pretty clearly does just on the substance of it. You know, the court's ready to address that. I think whether or not the mechanism poses a separate constitutional problem would be something else that a court would have to review as an argument distinct from Roe versus Wade. And whether or not that's a good one is something we've yet to see. I mean, we didn't see this in the original case
德克萨斯州的堕胎法是否违反宪法，而且在实质上它很明显是违宪的。你知道，法院准备解决这个问题。我想机制是否构成了单独的宪法问题将是法院必须审查的另一件事，作为一个不同于罗诉韦德案的论点。它是否是一个好的论点是我们尚未看到的。我的意思是，我们在法院在影子案卷中审查的原始案件中没有看到这一点。但这是一个好问题，也是一个令人不安的问题，因为如果我们让它不受限制，如果我们鼓励其他州立法机构做同样的事情，我们就是在激励州立法机构鼓励人们骚扰他人的宪法权利。所以在这个影子案卷意见中，他们提到它不是对法律本身合宪性的裁决。
that the court reviewed in a shadow docu. But it's a good question, and it's a troubling one, because if we let it go unchecked, if we encourage other state legislatures to do the same thing, we are incentivizing state legislatures to kind of encourage people to harass others with respect to their constitutional rights. So in the shadowed-dogget opinion, they mention that it isn't a ruling on the constitutionality
他们什么时候会对法律本身的合宪性做出裁决？他们将不得不等待那个正确的案件，那个正确的机会出现。所以现在，因为法院在9月1日午夜所做的事情，案件只是回到了它的程序，你知道，在联邦地方法院。那个特定的案件可能会提交给最高法院。它可能会采取德克萨斯州的另一个案件
of the law itself. When will they rule on the constitutionality of the law itself? They're going to have to wait for that right case, that right opportunity to come up. So right now, because of what the court did on September 1st at midnight, the case just goes back to its process, you know, at the federal district court. That particular case may go up to the Supreme Court. It may take a different case in Texas
提交给最高法院。然后还有问题是，在此期间，最高法院已经决定他们将在其任期内考虑一个堕胎案件，那就是密西西比州的法律。所以很多人只是担心，也许法院已经有五票要么彻底限制堕胎权利，
that comes up to the Supreme Court. And then there's the issue of, in the meantime, the Supreme Court's already decided that they're going to consider an abortion case for its term, that's the Mississippi law. So a lot of people are just worried anyway that maybe there are already five votes on the court to either radically restrict abortion rights
要么甚至做一些走得那么远的事情，推翻罗诉韦德案。是的。与此同时，在德克萨斯州堕胎只会变得更难。那是对的。而且你知道，别忘了，就像诺玛·麦考维本人一样，这真的很不平衡，对吧，当涉及到堕胎权利时，如果你是一个人，一个德克萨斯州的富有的人，你将能够获得堕胎服务提供者。但就像诺玛·麦考维本人一样，她当时失业，她的案件提交给了法院。她是一个想要堕胎的低收入者，
or maybe even do something go as far as overturned Roe versus Wade. Yeah. And in the meantime, it's only go to get an abortion in Texas. That's right. And you know, don't forget that just as with Norma McCorpio herself, it's really uneven, right, that when it comes to abortion rights, if you're a person, a wealthy person in Texas, you're going to have access to abortion services providers. But just like Norma McCorvey herself, who was unemployed at the time, her case went up to the court. She was a low-income person who wanted abortion,
但真的没有简单的方法获得一个。坦率地说，堕胎权利总是关于贫困女性的权利，对吧？我们真的没有手段前往另一个州去获得堕胎服务提供者。而且大概那个送他们去州外的人可能会被起诉？完全正确。那完全正确。那完全正确。我告诉过你程序很有趣。程序绝对很有趣。好吧，非常感谢你这次紧急会议，我很感激。谢谢，罗曼。
but really had no easy way to get one. Abortion rights, frankly, are always about the rights of poor women, right? We really do not have the means to travel to another state to access abortion services provider. And presumably the person that gave them a ride outside of the state could be sued? Exactly. That's exactly right. That's exactly right. I told you procedure was interesting. Procedure is definitely interesting. Well, thank you so much for this sort of emergency session, and I appreciate it. Thanks, Robin.
但实际上并没有简单的方法可以获得。坦率地说，堕胎权始终关乎贫困女性的权利，对吧？我们确实没有能力前往另一个州去获取堕胎服务。而且据推测，那个开车送她们出州的人也可能被起诉？没错。完全正确。完全正确。我告诉过你程序很有趣。程序确实很有趣。好吧，非常感谢你参加这次紧急会议，我很感激。谢谢，罗宾。
99% of Isabel was produced this week by Delaney Hall and edited by Chris Barube. Mixed in Tech Production by Dara Hirsch. Music by Director of Sound to Sean Rihau. Special thanks this week to Jill LePore. If you haven't heard her podcast, the last archive, make sure you check it out. It is fantastic. It's produced in the style of a classic 1930s radio drama, and it's about how we know what we know, and why it seems like lately, is if we don't know anything at all. Find it wherever you listen to podcasts.
本周的《99% Invisible》由Delaney Hall制作，Chris Barube编辑。由Dara Hirsch进行混音制作。音乐由声音总监Sean Rihau提供。本周特别感谢Jill LePore。如果你还没听过她的播客《The Last Archive》，一定要去听听。它非常棒。该节目以20世纪30年代经典广播剧的风格制作，探讨了我们如何认知事物，以及为什么最近感觉我们似乎什么都不知道。你可以在任何收听播客的地方找到它。
The episode of What Trump Can Teach Is About Con La, was produced by Elizabeth Jo and Chris Baroube, music courtesy of Doom Tree Records. Kurt Coleset is the digital director of 99% Invisible, the rest of the team includes Vivian Le, Joe Rosenberg, Lashemadon, Christopher Johnson, Emmett Fitzgerald, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. We are part of this Stitcher & Serious XM Podcast family. Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. And beautiful.
本期《What Trump Can Teach Us About Con Law》由Elizabeth Jo和Chris Baroube制作，音乐由Doom Tree Records提供。Kurt Coleset是《99% Invisible》的数字总监，团队其他成员包括Vivian Le、Joe Rosenberg、Lashemadon、Christopher Johnson、Emmett Fitzgerald、Sophia Klatsker以及我Roman Mars。我们是Stitcher和SiriusXM播客家族的一员。现在总部位于北边六个街区外的Pandora大楼。非常漂亮。
Uptown. Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars on the show at 99PI org. Well, on Instagram and Reddit too. You can find links to other Stitcher shows I love, as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do do There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，或关注节目账号@99PI.org。我们也在Instagram和Reddit上。你可以在99PI.org找到我喜欢的其他Stitcher节目链接，以及《99% Invisible》的所有往期节目。目前本集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。